Welcome to the Heavy Spoilers show I'm your
host Paul aka Billy The Squid and this video
we're breaking down the brand new Netflix
show Squid Game.
It's an absolutely incredible first season
that filled with lots of twists and turns
and throughout this video we're gonna be going
over the story, ending and what could be happening
in Season 2.
Full spoilers ahead so it's your choice whether
you want to proceed beyond this point but
I warn you there's no turning back.
If you enjoy the video then please smash the
thumbs up button and don't forget to subscribe
for breakdowns like this each and every day.
With that out the way, thank you for playing,
now let's get into Season 1 of Squid Game.
Ok so Squid Game follows Gi-Hun a man who's
down on his luck after losing just about everything
that means something to him.
His marriage failed, he lost his job, is in
deep over his head with gangsters and now
faces the fact that his daughter is going
to be leaving South Korea with her mother
and new family.
To make matters worse his mother is also at
deaths door and she requires medical treatment
in order to save his life.
Seems like things are going worse than this
channel is however his fortune seemingly changes
when he meets a man at a train station that
offers him the opportunity of a life and death
time.
Desperate for money Gi-Hun finds himself somewhat
squidnapped and drafted into a battle royale
between himself and 456 contestants worth
a grand prize of 45.6 billion.
Throughout we watch as the players are wittled
down to one in games of red and green, honey
combs, tug of war, hopscotch and one that
will have you losing your marbles due to the
betrayals in it.
The season is a blast to watch and early on
it sets up this idea of division within colours
that thematically ends up coming full circle
by the end.
The colours Red and Green are introduced and
these are actually classed as opposites on
the colour spectrum.
Both are mentioned in the passwords, they
become the name of the first game and even
the contestants wear green whilst the guards
don red.
The show is absolutely laced with these opposing
colours and they in many ways very much represent
the divide between the powerful and powerless.
As we know from our own society this divide
is often showcased between the rich and the
poor and we learn that there are a vast number
of wealthy men who actually oversee the entire
operation and that this is all for their entertainment.
Rather than being seen as people, the players
are very much just numbers and this is demonstrated
in the fact that they are literally given
these as their names.
Along the way, Gi-Hun meets an elderly man
named number 1 and the fact that he's the
first drafted into the game should give you
a clue towards his true identity at the end.
Gi-Hun is the last number in the game and
throughout the season we watch as he very
much works his way to 1.
At one point number 1 even ends the game and
gives the survivors of the first one a chance
to go off and live their lives but they all
return, desperate for the money.
In the end all that remains are Gi-Hun and
Sang-woo, two childhood friends who led very
different lives but both found themselves
in the same spot come the end of the game.
The final competition is the titular Squid
Game and we watch as the game they played
as children decides who will live and die.
It's an awesome final battle and they even
bring some rain in in order to add some dramatics
to the final showdown.
Gi-Hun bests Sang-Woo but rather than killing
him he brings up the clause that if both players
forfeit then the game will be null and void
and thus they'll both get to go home.
This will be with nothing but Gi-Hun would
rather put a stop to the death than gain the
money but rather than forfeiting Sang-Woo
ends his own life because of what he's done
in the game.
All he does is make Gi-Hun promise that he'll
look after his mother and then he stabs himself
leaving Gi-Hun as the last man standing.
Now whilst this game is going on we see a
police officer who's brother disappeared investigating
to island in an attempt to learn of his fate.
Throughout he sees things from the other side
but a big twist comes towards the end when
we learn that his sibling is actually a character
known as the Front Man who is running the
operation.
He attempts to alert the police to the whereabouts
of the island as well as what's going on but
the fact that the game is still continuing
at the end lets us know that the operation
wasn't shut down.
Now one of the big questions surrounding the
series is whether he survived or not.
Towards the end of the season he's shot and
though the character takes a tumble off a
cliff into the ocean, we never actually see
a body and therefore can assume that he's
still alive.
Hwang Jun-Ho is only shot in the shoulder,
much like his brother and with the Front Man
not dying from the wound it is likely that
his brother didn't either.
However we do know that he didn't shut down
the Squid Games so it'll be interesting to
see how he's brought back in future seasons.
After the prize money is given to Gi-Hun he
returns home but open getting there he finds
that his mother has died.
Due to him participating in the games he wasn't
there for her in her final few days and it's
a devastating ending that feels like a real
gut punch on what was already an extremly
brutal series.
It's at this point that we pick up one year
later and discover that Gi-Hun is still living
life in the exact same manner that he was
before he won.
The money that he saught after for so long
was actually worth nothing to him in the end
and the real people who meant something to
him were lost whilst he tried to seek out
these riches.
It's very much a case of the only thing worse
than not getting what you want is getting
it and he's trapped in a state of grief by
himself with life having lost it's meaning.
At this point he's given a card which is similar
to the one that started everything off and
on the back of it he finds an address which
leads him to an apartment.
Here he finds Number 1 bed bound and we learn
that he was actually behind the entire game.
Much like Gi-Hun, possessing all that money
ended up meaning very little to him and in
his boredom he created the games in order
to entertain himself and his rich friends.
He lived life believing that people wouldn't
help one another and uses a drunk man across
the street as confirmation of this.
In his last few moments he plays one final
game in which the pair bet whether anyone
will stop to help him and because of their
choices we see the cynicism within Number
1.
Number 1 or rather Il-Nam only believed in
the worst of humanity and his entire life
led him to believe that people were all self
centred only interested in...well their own
interests.
However as he dies we see that people actually
arrive in order to help the man across the
street and it's very much an FU to him in
his final moments.
Now we never learn whether Il-Nam as he's
called sees this but in all honesty it doesn't
really matter.
His entire life ended up becoming dedicated
to the idea that he didn't need to help others
because other people in his position would
also be just as selfish.
Il-Nam could've shared his wealth with anyone
at any time but he believed deep down that
people were all as bad as each other and that
if they were where he was that they wouldn't
help him either.
This was somewhat shown in the game of marbles
in which Gi-Hun lied and cheated in order
to get ahead.
Though we will never know whether he he knew
of the homeless man's fate or not it really
doesn't matter as this moment inspires Gi-Hun
to do something with the money rather than
letting it go to waste.
Gi-Hun gets a hair cut and has it dyed red
showing that he is somewhat the one that is
in the position of power now.
Rather than being a malevolent d**khead like
the rest of the reds though he takes a player's
brother out of an orphanage that she wanted
to rescue him from and places him in Sang-Woo's
care who he makes extremely rich.
He lives up to his two promises and though
it seems like a happy ending it's all quickly
cut short when we realise that the game is
still going.
Though Il-Nam died the game didn't die with
him and at a train station he comes across
the man who recruited him played by Gong Yoo.
You might recognise him from the seminal horror
movie Train To Busan and I believe that come
the second season that he will play a much
bigger role.
He is clearly still tied into the operation
and Gi-Hun takes the card from the person
he was attempting to rope into the game.
The season closes out with Gi-Hun about to
board a plane to LA in order to see his daugther
but after calling the number on the card he
comes to the conclusion that the game is going
to continue and that hundreds more people
will die if he doesn't step in and do something
about it.
He tells the Front Man that he's coming for
them and this of course carries a lot of weight
for Season 2.
Now I believe that Gi-Hun will meet up with
Hwang Jun-Ho and that together the pair will
end up going to the island in order to stop
the games.
Gi-Hun was gassed during transport so he doesn't
know how to get there, however Hwang Jun-Ho
does if he made it out and managed to swim
back to the mainland.
With Gi-Huns resources and new found life
he'll be able to equip Hwang Jun-Ho with the
necessary means to take down the Squid Game
Gang.
This is obviously a big twist as one of the
lessons he learned in his mothers death was
not to abandon those that he loved but he's
very much abandoning hundreds of people to
their deaths if he decides to travel to LA.
He's damned if he does and damned if he doesn't
and I see this more as an ending in which
he's sacrificing his own happiness in order
to help others.
Again this is something that Il-Nam would
never do and thus it's a great signal of the
character coming full circle.
Now there are other potentials for season
2 and we do know that the games have been
going on for decades.
There's evidence they even existed in the
80s and it would be interesting to explore
not only their origins but also Il-Nams who
of course founded them.
There's also the fact that we know these are
being run internationally and though it's
a long shot I'd love to see Netflix also bring
in the european and western games as series
to show us what was happening there before
we build to an overarching narrative involving
all the winners.
Either way there's a lot of potential directions
they could take it and I have to say I absolutely
loved this season and can't wait to see more.
It was absolutely gripping not knowing who
would live and die and it made for a season
that I happily binged in one day just to see
what the outcome would be.
This is a great character study that really
gets to the meat of what it means to survive
when it costs others so much and I think the
show handled a lot of it's elements in spectacular
fashion.
Whenever a Korean show comes out on Netflix
I always try and cover it as they're pretty
much brilliant across the board and this is
no different.
Squid Game pulled me right in and it gets
a...
9.5/10
Now obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the show and apologies if I butchered the
pronunciation of any of the names.
We're running a competition right now and
giving away 3 copies of the Zack Snyder DC
Trilogy on the 30th Of September.
All you have to do to be in with a chance
of winning is like the video, make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and drop a
comment below with your thoughts on the episode.
We pick the comments at random at the end
of the month and the winners of the last one
are on screen right now so message me @heavySpoilers
if that's you.
If you want something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of perfect
scene in Spider-Man Homecoming.
We break down the entire thing so it's definitely
worth checking out if you wanna know more.
With that out the way thank you for sitting
through the video, I’ve been Paul and I’ll
see you next time.
Take care, Peace